que te define la pregunta que les quiero
hacer para que reflexionen conforme les
voy contando mi historia de vida y mi
trayectoria que me ha hecho encontrar la
respuesta a esta pregunta
soy ingrid drexel clouthier tengo 28
años fui ciclista profesional durante 18
años empecé a los 8 muy chica mucha
gente pregunta por qué el ciclismo desde
chica mis padres me inculcaron la
actividad física el deporte provee de
todo y realmente cuando agarre la
bicicleta fue un amor a primera vista
fue una sensación de libertad sentir el
viento la adrenalina fue algo que me
encantó y que supe que quería hacer la
verdad es que nunca dimensione que fuera
a hacerlo de una manera profesional que
se pueda convertir realmente en mi
profesión
fui 8 años profesional le dedique como
ya les dije 18 años a este deporte pero
empecé por gusto o por amor por hobby
y jamás me imaginé lograron llegar hasta
hasta donde llegaría a los nueve años ya
estaba compitiendo en campeonatos
nacionales fui campeona nacional a los 9
10 11 12 años infantil después
olimpiadas nacionales tuve más de 40
medallas de oro me empezaron a llamar la
chica dorada la güera de oro
muchos apodos que me definían al final
del día y la gente me reconocía por eso
después fui campeona nacional 12 veces
digo perdón 8 veces más en la categoría
élite que es la máxima categoría
cuando tenía 14 años fui a mi primer
competencia internacional en un
campeonato panamericano yo todavía no
tenía la edad sin embargo porque ya
álava los tiempos y era muy buena pues
me seleccionaron y ahí fue cuando me
empecé a dar cuenta de que esto ya no
era solamente un hobby sino que se
estaba convirtiendo en algo más serio
tenía que empezar a tomar decisiones
es una edad complicada a todas estas muy
chicas yo seguía estudiando estaba en el
colegio con mis amigas empiezan las
reuniones las fiestas las llamadas
después pues las sillas la disco los
antros etcétera y yo tenía un compromiso
conmigo de que tenía que entrenar tenía
que competir y pues yo quería que me
fuera bien no entonces tendría que
empezar a balancear tomar decisiones
sobre qué camino seguir si quedarme pues
solamente en la fiesta y saliendo con
mis amigas o si realmente quería seguir
el camino que me dejara algo y que me
hiciera madurar como persona no al final
de cuentas decidió a los 15 años
pues seguir el camino del deporte
profesional
dedicarme al al 100% aunque seguía
estudiando nunca lo dejé al ciclismo
siempre balancea mi vida sin embargo
sabía que que pues ya había tomado esa
decisión y que era algo que quería hacer
porque era algo que amaba entonces pues
decidí tomar ese camino el cual no me
arrepiento muchas veces me decían
es que nunca sale es que no puedes
desvelarte no te puedes meter a la
alberca porque los músculos de te
aflojan y tienes que entrenar y no sé
qué entonces serán muchas restricciones
pero ahora algo que yo había decidido
hacer
empiezo
ya las competencias internacionales
empieza a obtener medallas fue también
múltiple medallista panamericana
fui medallista mundial también medalla
de plata y bronce
en el 2012 que era mi primer año de él y
tenía 18 años que es la máxima categoría
eran los juegos olímpicos de londres
realmente yo estaba muy chica obviamente
era una meta que como deportista casi
todo el mundo tenemos no ir a la máxima
justa y yo pues obviamente lo tenía no
sin embargo no en ese momento no era una
meta que tenía a tan corto plazo por mi
edad sentía que no tenía la experiencia
aún sin embargo la capacidad física la
tenía era estaba muy fuerte y bueno
hicieron los criterios criterios de
selección
gane todos los criterios de selección me
convierto en doble campeona nacional en
ese en ese momento pasan los días no
habían definido de repente estaba
entrenando aquí en monterrey recibe una
llamada estaba con mi entrenador y me
dicen felicidades va a ser a los
olímpicos de londres-2012
pues no sabe ni cómo reaccionar o sea
una niña de 18 años que byron los juegos
olímpicos y obviamente sale la noticia y
todo mundo está encima de ti todos los
medios tienes que dedicarle tiempo pues
a ellos no porque al final del día hay
que hay que darle también a la gente lo
que quiere escuchar pero no puedes
quitar el foco y de lo que estás
haciendo no de tus metas y objetivos
entonces es una línea muy delgada de osa
de que te puedes descarrilar antes de un
evento tan importante hay que saber
también mantener la mente firme saber
controlar las posiciones la presión
porque también en este momento ya es
eres olímpica te tienen que ir bien
están acostumbrados a verte ganar
siempre a verte en lo más alto del
pódium si no lo haces quién vas a hacer
cómo vas a responder mucha presión que
tienes de toda la gente que te ha
apoyado y que al final del día es algo
que tienes que aprender a controlar
voy a los olímpicos de londres estaba
toda mi familia y un día antes cumplo 19
años de antes de la competencia llega el
día de la competencia un 29 de julio me
paro en la meta empieza a llover
feísimo frío lluvia y yo sé a qué voy a
hacer yo nunca había competido en bajo
la lluvia a nosotros nos habían
acostumbrado aqui en mexico que cuando
yo hubiera o el clima estuviera feo se
suspenden las carreras pues ni modo hay
que hay que tomar pues ese ese riesgo
todos estábamos bajo la misma situación
y dije bueno es un terreno parejo para
todas
empieza la competencia iba muy bien me
sentía muy bien se quedaron los nervios
en en la meta conforme iba la carrera
todo iba perfecto salíamos del palacio
de buckingham nos íbamos a hacer las
afueras de londres damos dos vueltas a
un circuito en las afueras y regresamos
al palacio
cuando llegamos al circuito éramos
alrededor de unas 40 corredoras en ese
momento una curva a la izquierda una de
las corredoras se cae y nos tira como
unas 1520 corredoras ahí estaba yo en
esa caída no me pasó absolutamente nada
pude recoger mi bicicleta me paré y me
volví a subir sin embargo la punta de
carrera ya iba muy adelante no pudimos
conectar entonces como quien dice ahí
termino mi carrera yo terminé mi
participación yo dije que iba a llegar a
la meta sí o sí llegué a la meta había
granizo lluvia frío estaba llena de lodo
recuerdo ver a mi mamá que estaba
siempre apoyándome las competencias
estaba muy preocupada dónde está mi hija
dónde está mi hija porque no llegaba
porque a tus las que habían ganado ya
tenían como unos 15 minutos de haber
llegado yo no aparecía total aparezco
les cuento la anécdota y todo no y bueno
eso es ésa fue mi experiencia en juegos
olímpicos lógicamente pues después de
eso me quedó un hambre de querer
regresar y demostrar una vez que ya
tuviera la experiencia ya sabía lo que
era etcétera me preparo el siguiente año
recibo mi primer contrato como
profesional me voy a italia estuve
cuatro años en un equipo italiano
preparándome para río los olímpicos de
río ya estaba mucho más madura ya sabía
lo que era sabía lo que quería
estábamos en una competencia directa lya
yo había ganado ya la plaza para mexico
para los olímpicos de río y una mañana
me levanto y veo facebook
y una noticia de la federación
fulanita de tal va a ser la que
represente a méxico en los juegos
olímpicos de rio-2016 pues esa chava no
era yo
obviamente se te cae el mundo depresión
que voy a hacer porque yo no porque esto
ya no es single olímpica ahora la
olímpica de su lanita de tal quién soy
entran las dudas entran ya no quiero
hacer esto porque a seguir haciendo algo
si al final del día tú no tienes la
decisión final alguien más va a decidir
por ti de qué hacer hasta dónde llegar
me regreso a mi casa estaba en europa me
regreso a mexico
tomó un tiempo para reflexionar para
saber qué quería hacer ya me quería
retirar realmente ya no quería seguir y
en eso recibo cuatro o cinco ofertas
diferentes de equipos profesionales que
me querían y me puse a pensar
unos olímpicos no me definieron como
deportista no fui a los juegos olímpicos
de río pero si estoy recibiendo cinco
ofertas más de equipos profesionales
entonces dije algo tengo que estar
haciendo bien estas personas me están
bien no me están valorando saben lo que
lo que valgo como atleta como persona y
por algo me quieren decido seguir me
decido cambiar de aires también me voy a
eeuu estuve cuatro años con un equipo de
eeuu en el 2019 igual preparándote para
juegos olímpicos tokio 2020 porque
porque toda la gente te lo dice ya viste
a londres conseguiste la plaza para río
prepárate para tokio tú eres lo olímpica
tú puedes entonces te empiezan a poner
un sueño o alguna meta que probablemente
yo ya no quería
y fue ahí cuando me di cuenta que estaba
persiguiendo sueños que ya no eran míos
y que ya no me tocaban porque ya ya no
sentía ese amor y esa pasión por las
competencias por la bicicleta
entonces un día en el 2019 estando en
bélgica antes de iniciar mi temporada en
europa
me puse a llorar porque ya ya no
disfrutaba igual ya no ya no quería
seguir y no sabía cómo decirlo porque me
daba miedo me daba miedo ser ingrid sin
el ciclismo me da miedo ser ya no ser la
chica dorada' me daba miedo ya no ser la
olímpica me daba miedo de quién soy
después de esto si toda mi vida se lo ha
dedicado el ciclismo
sin embargo me di cuenta que al final
del día eso no me iba a definir como
persona
decidí tomarme un tiempo me regreso a
mexico
y después de varios tiempos sin la
bicicleta regresé a méxico y ni siquiera
la desempate la dejé empacada
y no le extrañe y empecé a hacer otras
cosas empecé a hacer otras cosas me
distraje mi esposo después me invitan a
un reality show en donde no iba a tener
comunicación iba a ser en otro país dije
es una oportunidad para encontrarme
conmigo misma saber qué es lo que quiero
porque no tenía en ese momento un camino
o un rumbo que seguir que tenga 18 años
de haber dedicado el ciclismo no
entonces voy al reality como les digo
sin comunicación sin nada no no sabía
este post a que iba ya no podías hablar
con nadie entonces yo creí que era el
momento perfecto para reencontrarme
conmigo misma
lo disfruté muchísimo fue una
experiencia que me ayudó mucho a eso yo
iba iba con un objetivo personal y lo
logré
después pues ya salgo del reality
regreso y regresé muy decidida de que
nada me iba a
definir y que yo no tenía que
demostrarle nada a nadie que no tenía
que hacer las cosas por los demás sino
que tenga que hacer lo que me gustaba a
mí las metas que yo tuviera fuera el
ciclismo fuera a ser mamá fuera a ser
esposa lo que fuera
muy importante saber que quería lograr
con esas cosas que estuviera haciendo
y que no te sintieras sin identidad si
dejaba de hacer eso a lo que le había
dedicado pues muchos años de tu vida o
mucho tiempo no
porque esas cosas al final del día no te
identifican y no te definen como persona
aprendí a enfocarme solamente en las
cosas que puedes controlar y creo que es
un mensaje muy muy potente
sólo enfocado en las cosas que puedes
controlar y dependen de ti porque si te
desgastas en los demás no vas a llegar a
ningún lado y solamente vas a vivir
frustrado
y escuchando una entrevista que le
hicieron a tom brady hace tiempo
me gustó mucho una frase que dijo cuando
le preguntaron sobre sus hijos tom brady
pues es uno de los jugadores sino que el
mejor jugador que ha tenido la historia
de la nfl le preguntan sobre sus hijos
oye son competitivos les gusta el fútbol
esto y que el otro y él contestó tengo
un hijo que es muy competitivo
que siempre quiere ser el mejor
y que le dice relájate y disfruta y esta
es la frase que me quedó muy grabada y
que le dijo traer be your best not the
best el hijo siempre quería ser el mejor
pero no era la mejor versión de sí misma
entonces le dijo solamente enfócate en
ser tu mejor versión y lo demás va a
venir no puedes estar luchando por ser
lo mejor en algo si no eres la mejor
versión de ti misma entonces eso es un
mensaje que me quedó muy grabado y creo
que pues nos puede servir a todos en
cualquier ámbito no solamente en el
deporte y bueno les vuelvo a preguntar
que te define eso que pensaste el inicio
vuelve la pensada ahorita a mí nada me
define solo soy y soy ingrid drexel
clouthier